thanks hope everything turns out okay
good luck
[Music]
mr jameson
oh yeah that was a good one mr jameson
come out come out wherever you are
mr jameson
oh boy
oh what happened well mr jameson was
here a minute ago and then he sort of
vanished what are you doing here yeah i
thought you were packing no
lisa's packing i just came by to get
these vouchers for a few weekends
flea i do not think so
missile jameson is so cheap he steals
towels from his own hotel
oh really look
oh these aren't vouchers this is money
money
how did that get in there you stole the
prize money
you'll play seath and a murderer
i'm calling the real police jeanette i
oh i'm sad
why'd you do it i mean if you needed the
money i would shut up screech this is
ridiculous i didn't kill anybody
tell it is it judge
[Music]
i didn't kill mr jameson why'd you take
the money i
didn't where'd you dump the body i
didn't did you really think you'd get
away with this no
i didn't i mean i i didn't do anything
take it easy darren he's just a kid
you know this whole thing is a setup i
just came here to play a stupid game as
soon as mr jameson disappeared it'd stop
being a game
yes and i want my necklace back oh
i am not a crook why don't you just ask
my friends all right
we will just what kind of a person is
zack morris
well he's the most honest person i know
well unless you count the time that he
sold fake ideas at school
but his mom grounded him for that zach's
never really done anything wrong
except the time he kind of sort of stole
our principal's car but he gave it back
i know zach pretty well and the last
thing he would do is steal
although you know there was that one
time where he kidnapped valley's mascot
but they deserved it
zach's my best friend i've written down
everything we've done together
see september 12th 1986.
and that was the day he taught me to the
roller coaster tracks remember that one
chuck
oh yeah you're a real sweetheart forgery
grand theft auto kidnapping oh and don't
forget attempted murder
yeah as soon as i get out of jail i'm
gonna murder you just wait til lisa gets
here
she'll tell you lisa you know jameson
told her about the vouchers too
she'll tell you what really happened
well then let's go find lisa
[Music]
we're pleased to tell these guys about
the vouchers lisa
she's not here yes i can see that slater
look i locked the door from the outside
no no no see what i mean she could have
gotten out
oh so she's just vanished
oh so poof i don't know
lisa oh zach what i am telling you i
left her here packing my suitcase
looks like she didn't get very far hello
what's this my necklace oh thank
goodness
what how did that get in there zack i'm
afraid we're going to have to search you
oh sure go ahead search me what do you
think you're going to find lisa hiding
in my shirt pocket
nice watch little dainty for you though
ain't it
it's lisa's watch oh zach you feed
you've murdered my future wife
lisa would never marry you oh sure now
you guys are nuts i'm telling you i've
been framed we'll see
for now everybody stay in your rooms
stay in my room
with that cold blooded butcher relax
screech i'll protect you oh slater i
knew you cared
zack if you go to jail i'll visit you
every sunday jay
thanks a bunch
so how'd you do it zach you're poisoned
your lipstick
whoa whoa down boy chill out guys
something really weird is going on here
guys
we got to figure out how lisa got out of
this room
woody i'm serious i mean how could she
get out without the key
i mean both the door and the windows
were locked
maybe there's a secret passage giving
you a break a secret passage
like if i turn this candle here the
wall's gonna open up
you